jérémy entend toutes les parties se
prononcer sur la question nationale
parce que je pense que certaines
questions ont été déviés environnement
on en a parlé un peu mais pas
suffisamment d'éducation pas
suffisamment aussi j'aime et qui
développe un peu plus loin les projets à
mener pour sow qui nous a faits concrets
qui vont faire pour l'environnement et
les débats confirmer votre wii
pleinement oui
voilà quelques commentaires de citoyens
ce matin au lendemain du débat des chefs
vous avez peut-être regarder hier à la
télévision
michel david michels et auger bonsoir
bonsoir on va essayer de on a dit
beaucoup de choses depuis hier les
heurts ont pas un type c'est intéressant
parce qu'il ya le débat mais à la
journée aussi que j'aimerais analyser
avec vous j'aimerais vous faire entendre
d'abord pour lancer la discussion
cet extrait de madame marois et de
pierre karl péladeau c'était ce matin où
on voulait vraiment parler d'autre chose
que de référendum d'économie de chartes
on écoute je crois qu'au contraire c'est
très clair est-ce qu'on veut revenir aux
années libéral qui n'ont pas été des
années très heureuse pour le québec
quand on pense à tous les problèmes de
corruption quand on pense à l'opposition
qui ont eu les 18 membres de l'équipe
libérale qui formaient le gouvernement
charest qui sont toujours dans l'équipe
de monsieur couillard les enjeux sont
clairs québec qui veut avancer vers
l'emploi vers des règles claires en
matière du bien vivre ensemble une
charte de la laïcité
la réponse est claire nette et précise
je me suis engagé pour le parti
québécois pour l'économie et j'ai
toujours été démonstratif
c'est ma nature j'ai un engagement
profond envers l'économie et c'était
aussi le signe de cet engagement
il voyait messieurs derrière bernard
drainville qui lui a parlé de la charte
en 10 rebonds l'économie l'achat pour
quand ça 06 eur dont on veut parler dans
cette campagne électorale
mais autre extrait ou une candidate dans
bellechasse ancien ministre linda goupil
a dit ceci réaction du chef libéral
si on m'avait parlé d'un référendum dans
ce mandat je ne serai pas candidate au
parti québécois
vous en voulez bon ce n'est pas ce que
je vous ai dit vous me demandez si linda
goupil est pour ou contre un référendum
n'a franchement de la réponse elle est
non
clairement on est dans une confusion
organisé par aussi de cacher encore le
scénario référendaire je me titille
déclaration ensemble madame mao débat
qui n'est pas capable de dire qui aura
pas de référendum
le ch lisez encore lui qui revient hier
qui est dit dans le fond sentant
peut-être pas la première année mais on
va s'arranger pour ramener un après bram
goupil qui dit qu'elle serait pas venu
en politique si t'es pas su qu'ils
allaient avoir un référendum alors
monsieur péladeau lui disait qu'il
serait pas venu en politique si elle
n'est pas avoir de référence alors c'est
la confusion totale
la question c'est celle là ils peuvent
pas s'en sauver c'est eux mêmes qui
l'ont mis sur la table la question de
l'élection d'un gouvernement pour un
référendum où un gouvernement pour
l'économie l'emploi la postérité
je l'avais dit c'est pas facile
d'enlever ce sujet-là de la table un
petit sujet le référendum a souhaité
passer pas passer mais je pense que ça
sera pas jusqu'à la fin voyez la
formulation que madame awa étudié hier
c'était presque mot pour mot la
plateforme de bernard landry en 2003 il
y aura un référendum quand la population
de voudra de 7 heures et 7 heures à
partir de ce moment-là de mets toi on a
pu parler du tout mais on n'est plus en
2003 et il y avait pire car justement
mais pourquoi on en reparle
parce que lucien bouchard fin de
campagne sur les conditions gagnantes
vous avez parlé de bernard landry
également pourquoi ça lui colle à la
peau comme ça lui colle à la peau à
cause de monsieur péladeau qu'un
monsieur couillard deux trois semaines
avant le début de la campagne par les
deux soeurs en dizaines qu'est-ce qu'il
fallait lui son bonhomme sept heures ce
n'est pas crédible du tout c'est
monsieur péladeau qui est venu
crédibiliser toute cette ce scénario-là
est évidemment quand on voit aujourd'hui
j'ai levé le bras pour parler je me suis
trompé de mots dans le formulaire
économique du pays
c'est difficile à croire alors ça va
être très très michel c il faut pas
oublier une chose le pq n'a gagné qu'une
seule élection quand il était dans le
flou le des conditions gagnantes des ont
franchi quand les québécois sont prêts
c'est 98 y ont pas eu la majorité des
voix lyon est aujourd'hui les siens je
vais passer le détroit
ils ont jamais gagné une élection
majeure et un mandat majoritaire
c'est pas pour rien les deux référendums
qui ont eu lieu à 81,95 à l'élection
précédente le pq avait demandé
formellement la permission de les tenir
le référendum alors on savait à quoi
s'en tenir stackler sur bariseau c'est
clair ce monsieur minc là cette fois
depuis six ans la gantoise au fond pas
de stratégie ouverte mais on a john en
france quand on n'en voudra un moment
donné il n'est pas étonnant que l'autre
partie disent ils vont le faire dans ce
mandat si vous allez voir ils vont faire
asseoir dessus
et qu'est ce que vous pensez d'une
ancienne milice l'un des groupes ltd
fois dans une campagne électorale d'un
candidat totalement inconnu qui gaffe
puisque ça rigole ça peut embêter ou pas
le chef c'est une ancienne mine is linda
goupil candidate dans bellechasse le
parti québécois veut reprendre sa
circonscription la qui dit moi j'en veux
pop si j'avais si on m'avait dit qu'un
terrain
je serai pas candidat ou qu'est-ce que
ça produit comme l'effet direct et à
tout ce qu'elle vient à nettement je me
souviens de la première version madame
goupil quand elle avait été nommée à
l'âge où ça la justice se tait c'est un
gars sur gaffe s'était replacé à la
famille mais au départ c'est j'ai
l'impression de retrouver la bad à mme
goupil premières manières sa convaincre
personne voyons madame goupil on lui dit
enfin référendum on va le gagner non non
non non j'avais pas là dedans je pense
qu'après je comprends que c'est
bellechasse que c'est un conte équipe
fédérale disent que d'autres mais c'est
pas vrai que michel est ce que ça dit
aussi beaucoup sur le contexte de québec
ou peut-être encore plus qu'ici l'idée
de ce référendum ou délire au
gouvernement qui fera un référendum on
veut pas en entendre parler
c'est quoi l'expression anglaise au
report de taxes locales truc tout les
enjeux politiques sont locaux si madame
goupil veut gagner bellechasse faut
qu'elle dise c'est bizarre a des
répercussions dans le reste de la
campagne évidemment mais on sait qu'à
québec on a vu c'est le premier sondage
montrait que sur le couillard était
passé en avant c'était la région de
québec
les radios de québec on sait l'effet que
ça peut avoir ils font pratiquement
campagne ouvertement pour le choukouya
alors les liens contexte particulier qui
est vrai que c'est pour la première fois
qu'on se rencontre très bien et je veux
qu'on reparle de ce débat on verra des
images donc on le dit a pas eu joue à
chaud vous l'avez dit hier quelques
minutes après y'a pas eu de carreaux pas
de très grands gagnants pas de très
grands perdants non plus juste pour
c'est intéressant quand même notre
boussole électorale les gens il ya quand
même cinq mille 5000 29 l'utilisateur
qui ont voté pour qui selon elle avait
gagné et bien philippe couillard arrivé
qu 33 pour ça madame marois 22 françoise
david 15 françois legault 14 et 16 % ne
sait pas donc quand même grands groupes
qui ne n'arrivait pas vous disiez ça
correspond impose intentions de vote
dans ce sens là ma question est ce que
ça change quelque chose ce débat là non
ça change pas la tendance générale est
sur quelque chose ça peut même
l'accélérer
la mesure où monsieur legault a
travaillé bien fort pour monsieur
couillard hier soir c'était étonnant
c'est vrai que monsieur le goût est
celui qui a lancé le plus de coups mais
ce n'était pas à lui de commencer à
steene et madame marois piles usées vous
évoluez allez vous faire un référent oui
ou non
ce faisant il invitait presque sa propre
guerre ça déplacé vers les libéraux
alors dans ce sens là il était très bon
mais sa stratégie était très mauvaise
pour la cac
oui parce qu'il n'ya pas attaquer celui
qui lui volent des votes actuellement il
y avait l'air de quelqu'un qui dit si je
suis pour mourir gens choisir le
prochain premier ministre
mais franchement l'air de savoir et un
moment donné il faut dire qu'il ya un
vieux contentieux damas voir monsieur
legault on sait ça depuis longtemps on a
peut-être que c'est ça je ne sais pas on
peut pas entrer dans la danse dans leur
esprit mais en même temps il est clair
que ça risque de continuer parce que
d'abord madame marois a essayé de mettre
le couvercle sur la marmite mais c'est
un couvercle qui fit pour looking équipe
a tout à fait de la bonne grandeur
elle n'a pas dit non à l'a dit non mais
alors un nom mais cela peut vouloir dire
oui deuxièmement monsieur couillard a eu
un débat car porter spectaculaire mais
où il n'est pas tombé lui non plus alors
pour les gens qui faisaient de quoi il
ya quoi il aurait l'air comme premier
ministre il s'en est pas trop mal tiré
et le problème et risque même si j'ai
l'impression qu'on va finir par en
parler un petit peu moins dans les
prochains jours quitte à y revenir
beaucoup beaucoup dans leurs portes
quatre jours que vont rester là le jour
du vote mais je pense que dans l'esprit
des gens c'est déjà largement incrusté
alors même si on n'en parle pas pendant
deux trois jours ça disparaîtra pas
comme ça est ce que vous attendez à un
changement de ton à des attaques
peut-être même à des dérapages là on va
jouer bon on est dans les deux ans sera
dans les derniers milles
dans la stratégie au parti québécois
revenir avec des histoires de corruption
libérales etc
on va être dans l'émotion beaucoup plus
et ça augmente les risques de dérapage
si on parle de chambre des valeurs la
charte des valeurs c'est quelque chose
des motifs pour la plupart des gens ont
soif la station qui veulent construire
ou qu'on soit contre le sait quelque
chose des motifs des questions de
corruption ont toujours donné des débats
et mois de ses fonctions sans voilà
c'est peut-être payant pour le parti
québécois mais en même temps ça augmente
le risque de dérapage faut savoir que
les deux sont possibles
oui mais il va venir un moment donné où
on va vouloir jouer le tout pour le tout
hier sur ces questions là on était très
modéré je m'attends mois ont convergé
les parties vont avoir leurs propres
sondages mais je m'attends à ce que le
deuxième débat soit un peu plus corsé
que celui d'hier et parce que si on
enlève les gants blancs puis qu'on
frappe un peu plus fort sur les tic les
attaques contre monsieur couleurs sont
pas venus hier mais pour être pu faire
un certain al marri et sébastien ont
parlé de duke apporteront parler du deal
ou présumés avec l'achat mais personne
n'a repris 100 mais il ya une malchance
aussi c'est que le tirage au sort
faisait qui avait pas de face-à-face
entre madame marois que monsieur
couillard à son éthique c'est les règles
du débat qui ont voulu ça faisait la fin
de tout le monde peut-être c'est sûr que
ça va sortir la prochaine fois
et la chose qui fait mal hein monsieur
couillard faut pas l'oublier c'est pour
monsieur partage c'est le plq lui-même
sow pl tuque eu des perquisitions du
pacs et au plq cas une enquête sur le
financement
mais jusqu'à preuve du contraire lui pas
que nous dit pas ce qu'a fait la
meilleure nappe au pq michel c michel
david
merci beaucoup alors à vendredi prochain
on aura la question sur parlé ici salut